القبعة الصفراء،
هذه العينة الذهبية الغامضة تم
العثور عليها خلال رحلة استكشافية في أعماق البحار في
خليج ألاسكا، إنها نوع من
الإسفنج المغطى،
نعم، لا أعرف ماذا أفعل من أن
العلماء على متن سفينة نوح،
مستكشف أوكيانو، يقولون إنهم اكتشفوها على بعد حوالي
ميلين  تحت السطح،
لا أعرف ما الذي أفكر فيه حول هذا الأمر،
يبدو أننا نرى في الدردشة
مرفقًا إسفنجيًا ميتًا
[موسيقى]
فريق إسفنجي
ولكن الآن أرى حالة بيضة محتملة
يمكنني رؤيتها أيضًا يطلق عليها اسم
الذهبي  يقول الباحثون في الجرم السماوي إنهم
لم يتمكنوا حتى الآن من تحديد هويته
ولكنهم أكدوا أنه بيولوجي. الأصل
نعم، دعنا نعطيه القليل من الدغدغة
يا ناعم
[موسيقى]
الهواء الحراري حسنًا،
فقط ينهار إذا حاولت الاستيلاء عليه،
يبدو الأمر كما يبدو
أخذها علماء دقيقون جدًا إلى المختبر
لمعرفة المزيد عنها